in a wild year in the markets the
riskiest asset
is one of the hottest bitcoin bitcoin
bitcoin there's no value it's a bubble
bitcoin may well be a substitute for
gold you can see it on this chart
after a historic climb and crash three
years ago bitcoin
is at it again like last time a surge of
investor enthusiasm is driving it to
all-time highs
and bitcoin bulls say this is only the
beginning
they see bitcoin as a revolution in
financial systems
they have been pushing this for about 11
years they are
finally getting people to listen to them
but many bears watching bitcoin warn
that the asset is too volatile for
average investors and that it's a purely
speculative
bet that won't be able to scale we'll
explain
[Music]
the way bitcoin works is key to
understanding why it's so popular
unlike other investments the
cryptocurrency isn't tied to physical
assets
or the us dollar the purpose of bitcoin
is just
to allow two people anywhere to exchange
value directly
what that means is that there is no one
central party controlling this
network there is no government there is
no central bank
that could shut this down or arbitrarily
raise or lower the value
at its core bitcoin is purely software
it runs on a network of interlinked but
independent computers they form a ledger
of transactions between
people across the world instead of that
ledger being controlled by a single
master computer
or a single party the information is
copied on every computer that is part of
the network
this is a cryptocurrency blockchain it
can be reviewed by anybody it can be
seen by anybody
what that does is it prevents
counterfeiting it prevents double
spending
it makes bitcoin a secure currency
every time someone makes a transaction a
unique encrypted signature is
added to the ledger for verification
once a transaction is confirmed and
completed
that signature cannot be changed it
cannot be altered essentially it means
you can't counterfeit a bitcoin
that's what keeps the network honest
many bitcoin bulls argue that the
network is
unhackable but that's not necessarily
true the
issue is that to hack it you would have
to take over the network
and to take over the network you would
need your own network of computers
running 24 7 and to do that
would cost billions of dollars you can
do it
but is it worth it no and while anyone
can download and run the program to
become part of the blockchain network
no one has the ability to make universal
changes
bitcoins not yet available to the public
are created through a process known
as mining miners use powerful computers
to solve complex math problems to
process bitcoin transactions
this process unlocks new digital coins
but
these coins aren't limitless bitcoin's
founding code was embedded with the
condition
that there would always be a finite
number of coins available
this scarcity is what gives bitcoin
value
right now about 18.5 million of the 21
million maximum bitcoins have already
been mined
but the way the network is set up every
four years
the reward per batch of transactions
confirmed per mining puzzle
solved gets cut in half so
the 21st millionth bitcoin will not be
created until
basically sometime around the year 2140
and while the number of available
bitcoins is growing the demand for them
is growing faster
this demand has a lot to do with how
individual investors are trading
bitcoin is becoming easier to buy on
apps like paypal
square and robinhood which is drawing
more novice
retail investors who are looking for
quick returns while trading at home
so far this year there have been more
than 38 million
small bitcoin transfers trades that are
less than a thousand dollars
this is up from about 20 million in
2017.
larger institutional investors are
piling in as well
what's really going to be interesting
over the next couple of years to watch
is the degree to which central banks
start to digitize their own currencies
as financial systems become more digital
it's leading to bitcoin becoming more
mainstream
but the digital currency's resurgence is
also closely tied to the state of global
finance
when the coronavirus pandemic hit when
you had the central banks respond the
way they
did what they did was push down interest
rates
lowered the value of their currencies
that's made bitcoin essentially
a hedge against the dollar the value of
the dollar is going down bitcoin
proponents say
the value of bitcoin should be going up
what we've seen in the last couple of
months is that people are interested in
assets that have high returns
they are willing to take risks and one
of the highest returned highest risk
assets
anywhere in the capital market is
bitcoin this potential for
big profits is driving a frenzy of
momentum trading
and for many investors these bets are
paying off the digital currency
is up about 220 this year
one reason investing in bitcoin is so
risky is how small the market is
the total value of bitcoin and
circulation right now is around 420
billion dollars
the value of apple stock just apple is
about two trillion dollars
the value of the financial market for
gold
is north of 12 trillion dollars so
bitcoin is still very small doesn't take
a lot of people to come in
and push the value up the the smallness
of the market
contributes to these sort of explosive
price moves that we've seen
and because the cryptocurrency is
decentralized there is no
insurance backing it there are no
backstops to it it could go down to zero
tomorrow
and there would be nothing to stop it
there are no circuit breakers there are
no closing bills in bitcoin trading
until the market matures experts warn
that the price of bitcoin will continue
to see
volatile swings so is it risky
[Music]
yes